[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
juan's at the ready state of play is
back with an in-depth look at the magic
brewing in hogwarts legacy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
lumos
what do you think you're doing here
humans
welcome to hogwarts legacy
you're a new student at the famed school
of witchcraft and wizardry with a unique
ability to manipulate powerful ancient
magic hidden in the wizarding world
you'll need to uncover what's behind the
return of this forgotten magic and who
is seeking to harness it to destroy
wizard kind as you may be the one that
decides the fate of the entire wizarding
world
but before you can study magic and begin
to solve these mysteries you must create
the witch or wizard you want to be
when you arrive at hogwarts you will be
sorted into one of the four hogwarts
houses gryffindor hufflepuff ravenclaw
or slytherin after you settle into your
dormitory you will meet up with your
housemates in the common room you will
then need to attend classes and you do
have some catching up to do as you were
starting hogwarts late as a fifth year
so you are the new student
you'll begin your studies attending
charms defense against the dark arts
herbology and potions classes to name a
few
oh hello
class
please welcome the newest rose in our
garden
shall we begin
welcome to year five of chance now this
will be a crucial year in your education
on the art of charm work but i am
confident that we will take hold with a
passion and rigor requisite of such a
challenge
the best way to practice is by dueling
we'll start with youtube
time for a proper hogwarts welcome
you may begin
[Music]
is one of the most challenging and
hazardous subjects taught at this school
here you'll meet your professors and
learn to cast spells grow magical plants
brew potions and more in between classes
you'll be able to explore the castle
famous for its secrets
enchantments and mysteries
you'll discover dungeons and secret
passageways
[Music]
as well as challenging puzzles that will
require magical skill and a clever mind
to solve
[Music]
you may even find yourself in iconic
locations you've never been able to
explore before
[Music]
it's the late 1800s so while the common
rooms and classes may be familiar most
of your professors will not be however
you may recognize a few faces
all in good fact once a patrick lets me
join the headless hunt i'll be right
there with them this offering is sure to
bring them over oh don't forget why i'm
here sir
you'll come to know this eclectic group
of talented witches and wizards in class
and while completing side assignments
that are part of a special curriculum
ones designed to help you catch up with
the other fifth years at your own speed
[Music]
opportunities for adventure abound in
the area surrounding hogwarts
the magical abilities you learn to
master through your schoolwork will soon
become tested as you unravel a dangerous
mystery by working alongside the
accomplished and yet enigmatic professor
fig to try and discover if the rumors of
a mounting goblin rebellion hold any
weight and if the safety of hogwarts
lies in the balance i have
opinions differ as to how great a threat
he really is
[Music]
loyalists are capable of so much more
than people realize the wizarding world
of this era is fraught with dangers
creatures corrupted by a magical force
powerful goblins
and sinister witches and wizards all
willing to fight even kill to achieve
their own goals
in fact there's an uneasy alliance
between the goblins and dark wizards you
said you could get to the child when
they came to hogsmeade that all you
needed was a distraction i gave you a
distraction i just watched a student
take down your distraction
who is this child you're not telling me
but perhaps you shouldn't involve
yourself with that just yet
repairing
[Music]
enemies possess unique defensive and
offensive abilities including blasting
curses stunning spells enchanted
weaponry and more while some may attack
directly others might enchant and
incapacitate you
mastery of the shield charm allows you
to deflect ranged spells and direct
weapon strikes
counter-attack with powerful stunning
charms allowing you to follow up with
extended spell combinations
[Music]
students who become particularly adept
at spell casting will find many ways to
exploit their enemies weakness
[Music]
slam with descending
roast with incendio
devastate your enemies using various
finishes
you can even use the mysterious powerful
magic your professors do not understand
to obliterate your strongest foes
mixing and matching dozens of spells
will let you define your combat style
on your path to become the ultimate
duelist
[Music]
perhaps you'd be good enough to blast
each other to pieces on your own time
in addition to classes and spells you'll
have access to a deep set of upgrades
talents and skills to aid your
progression as a wizard
complete challenges throughout the world
to earn experience level up your
abilities by choosing talents to upgrade
your spells plants and potions to
increase their power decide which
talents best fit your playstyle to allow
you to focus on your favorite types of
magic
you can also loot buy or craft your own
magical gear
that will increase your offensive and
defensive capabilities in combat
gear can be upgraded and specialized to
allow for greater abilities for your
chosen playstyle use a strong even
motion when crossing your ingredients
[Music]
spells are not the only tools at your
disposal in combat as you hone your one
skills you can continue to further your
magical education at hogwarts
progressing your development as a witch
or wizard
brew potions that can increase your
power when you need a boost
[Music]
grow and deploy magical plants to mob
the battlefield and keep your enemies at
bay
[Music]
you can even unleash deadly mandrake
seedlings to incapacitate unsuspecting
enemies
in beast's class you will learn about a
variety of magical beasts you might
encounter both at school and as you
explore the world surrounding the castle
and its grounds the goal of today is to
remind all of you how to maneuver on a
broomstick safely
[Music]
learning and mastering broom flight is
highly recommended so that you may
travel around the world more quickly
i want you to do my herbology homework
you're despicable
some abilities may be taught to you by
students who become your friends
[Music]
as you develop relationships with these
schoolmates they can accompany you on
your journey as your companions
[Music]
and over time you'll learn their stories
[Music]
this is our chance
is a brave adventurer driven by the
justice she seeks
poppy sweeting has a kind heart and
loves magical beasts connecting with
them more easily than with humans
what happens now unafraid of detention
or breaking the rules sneaking in the
restricted section again is sebastian
sallow a charismatic slytherin we've
been over this boy triple figs cannot
reverse a curse with a troubling family
secret nothing can the sooner you accept
that reality the better you'll meet
these students and more as you explore
common rooms hallways between classes
and regular gathering areas
welcome to the room of requirement
[Music]
one of the most remarkable secrets of
hogwarts is known as the room of
requirement
[Music]
you're introduced to this space that
seems to sense what you need and then
provides it for you
[Music]
since you need to catch up to your peers
the room provides space for you to sew
and harvest plants brew potions and
upgrade your gear
[Music]
a helpful house elf named deke helps you
discover the variants that allow you to
nurture your own menagerie of magical
beasts what is it
dick isn't sure
only one way to find out you can freely
customize this space to reflect your
personality and magical specialties
[Music]
[Music]
not everything you need on your journey
is available at hogwarts you'll want to
visit the nearby wizarding village of
hogsmeade where loads of shops and
vendors can provide you with the
supplies you require
[Music]
from potion ingredients and recipes
to seeds for magical plants to all sorts
of gear
but hogsmeade also has its dangerous
side a band of dark witches and wizards
emboldened by the turmoil of the times
wander the village outskirts
you must avoid them or defeat them
as you explore you'll find the world
surrounding hogwarts is alive with
activity wonders and areas of unusual
interest
as the school year progresses dynamic
seasons and climates will fill the sky
with lightning or sunshine or coat the
ground with snow or rain
unique wizarding hamlets pepper the
countryside
each with vendors and residents who have
stories to tell
and missions with which they could use
your assistance
be on the lookout for enchanting magical
puzzles that may very well have been
designed by merlin himself
when he was a student at hogwarts
magical beasts roam the lands outside
the castle walls some have been
corrupted by a mysterious dark magic
while others are at risk of poachers and
their traps if you're feeling benevolent
you can rescue them and restore them to
health in the room of requirement
but there are dangers beyond your
understanding in the world as well
dungeons and vaults hold perilous
threats and also untold rewards
be careful where you choose to explore
as it may lead you down a darker path
master spells
befriend new allies journey across a
landscape never seen before uncover
ancient secrets combat mystical threats
learn long forgotten mysteries become
the witch or wizard you want to be
as you leave your unique mark on the
wizarding world
here in hogwarts legacy
that was your first extended look at
hogwarts legacy
now let's hear from the real wizards and
witches behind the game
the attention to detail and the passion
and
the love for this brand that the team
has is astonishing
[Music]
our team is so excited to take all of
the love that they put into this as fans
and give it to fans this is the game
that they've dreamed of for 20 years
[Music]
the lore of the wizarding world is
already so rich
and all we had to do was harness those
elements and
build a game out of it
the movies the books they all touched me
in such a way that it makes me want to
go to
experience hogwarts makes me put in so
much more detail into this game
[Music]
we really want to make sure that
anything we add or anything we play with
or anything that we explore really feels
authentic bringing to life just the
charm and the love everything we have
for the books
and then marrying that with the iconic
experiences from the movies that fans
will recognize
is really just the perfect handshake
between the two
[Music]
just the discovery of like seeing things
portrayed for the first time maybe
they've read something and had a picture
in their head the whole time but then
finally to get to touch it to walk
around it you've got all these elements
that can come together to create this
amazing
aaa open world action rpg when it comes
to the open world it's just we just knew
it wasn't going to be enough to just
stare out of the windows of hogwarts and
wonder what it's like out there but the
final question that fans ask is what's
beyond that what's beyond the forbidden
forest what's going to be beyond
hogsmeade what's beyond the black lake
if i start traveling south and we just
felt like we had to answer those
questions
[Music]
[Applause]
we're creating a real wide palette of
opportunities and ways to explore the
world you're going to see different
stories that are really exclusive to who
you were in the world hogwarts legacy is
an original story that takes place in
the late 1800s you are a new student who
is starting at the famed school of
witchcraft and wizardry as a fifth year
which is very unusual so already there's
a bit of an edge and a bit of a mystery
the original story that we tell in the
game is your story of what you did you
know in the wizarding world that you
haven't seen before or make our own
magic with our story we're trying to
tell fans are familiar with the
wizarding world from you know the 1900s
and on really but now with this world
we're able to sort of
create a space that's their own
fans of the series will know that
ancient magic
has been around for a long time to say
the least and that hogwarts itself is a
stronghold of ancient magic
and the avatar the player
has the ability
to sense it
and possibly wield it or control it our
process of development started with
rereading the books
and over development we reread the books
many times
every time we'd start with a new feature
we'd dig into that and then beyond we
would go into the films
[Music]
being able to put our own
spin on what this universe is was a
pretty big deal
i helped design a piece that nobody has
ever seen before the hufflepuff common
room
you know as a hufflepuff you always
wonder like what what is my common art
supposed to look like it's close enough
to the world that we know
that fans will recognize certain names
they'll recognize spells they'll
recognize certain locations i recognize
that doorway i recognize that classroom
but mostly it's going to be an entirely
new wizarding world that no one's ever
experienced
when people engage in the wizarding
world what's the one anchor like what's
the thing that everyone comes back to
what's the thing that grounds it all and
grounds all these characters and grounds
all these figures and for us we really
felt like that answer was hogwarts
itself that school that famous school of
witchcraft and wizardry is really what
binds it all
how to bring hogwarts to life
that was a very big challenge because as
everybody knows hogwarts is huge now we
need to know exactly how this passage
connects to this passage for a game
because you're gonna have to walk it and
of course again sentient castle it's
it's got new surprises up its sleeves it
likes to keep its students on its toes
we've put so many little secrets and
passageways and rooms in this castle
we recreate those very important
locations and then there's these other
places that are only mentioned in the
books or just alluded to and we have to
make the connective tissue that brings
all that together
having a world that is a breathing
living world is very hard to do because
it's all about the details
and as a concept team we really
got into those details and studied
history studied architecture
i hope that when fans play the game they
get as lost in it as i do i can just be
reviewing a side mission and all of a
sudden i find myself wandering hogwarts
for like 45 minutes because it's so
beautiful the community is absolutely
going to love hogwarts legacy it's gonna
be so fun get that letter to hogwarts
and go to hogwarts we're so excited for
people to come to this to inhabit it to
actually enter the hogwarts that we
built this is your hogwarts legacy
we truly hope you enjoyed the hogwarts
legacy state of play our team is so
grateful for the excitement and for the
passion that all of you bring to this
it's truly what fuels us
on behalf of our team at wb games
avalanche we want to thank you for being
here today and we'll see you at hogwarts
that's our show we hope you're excited
for the magic to come see you next time
[Music]
you